do you think the universe has a
beautiful clean
when you show up and meet God and
there's one equation on the board and
the two of you just chuckle do you think
such equation exists
yeah there are such equations
let's say I am
interesting particular question right so
in the language program say so moving
away from physics so let's talk about
math so
in in the context of language program
I have recently developed with my
co-authors
done and kind of a new strand a new
flavor of the language program if you
will
but so far it's a sort of it's a vision
it's a set of conjectures which we have
proved in some cases but not in full
generality
so yes I would like to to use your
framework for me the Creator and ask her
what is the explanation of this and it
may well be that you will answer in a
way that I will I will just burst out
laughing it's like how could we not see
it you see so that I totally see
but I don't see one equation governing
one one equation governing them all
not one equation to govern them all but
it does seem that such equations exist
what she will tell you something and you
look back and say how could I not see it
it seems like the the truth at the end
of the day is simple
that we're seeking especially through
mathematics it seems somehow simple
the the nature of reality the thing that
governs it seems to be simple I wonder
why that is
and I also wonder if it's not totally
Incorrect and we're just craving the
simplicity
and then
mixing into the whole conversation about
how much The Observer that creates
Simplicity is part of the answer
it's a whole big giant mess
or a whole a whole big beautiful
painting
or Symphony